[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
opening ceremony of the 2021
saint louis rapid in blitz
it is indeed been a difficult year for
all of us this pandemic has thrown a
wrench into many of our plans so it is
certainly without hyperbole to say that
the st louis chess club and the
organizers of the grand chess tour have
done a magnificent job in putting
together the tour so far and making sure
that the players have continued to feel
comfortable making this event what it
has been we've had three great events
uh already we started in romania had a
fantastic event there in bucharest well
organized we then moved on to paris and
then to zagreb and now we are here at
the capital of chess in the united
states st louis to close out this grand
chess tour i'd like to thank shannon
bailey and the world chess hall of fame
for hosting this event thank you so much
shannon and your staff
and of course i'd like to thank
the couple without whom none of this
would have taken place
dr jeannie and rex singfield thank you
[Applause]
and i would like to thank
gary kasparov the brainchild of the
grand chess tour mike kotakovsky
the executive director and tony rich
who's the executive director of the st
louis chess club for their leadership in
making all this run as smoothly as it
does
[Applause]
we also want to thank our sponsors
superbad and augusta and sasha dragetch
vivendi and key square in paris along as
along with zlatko and superbet sponsors
in croatia without their support their
continued support this doesn't happen
thank you so much for all your
generosity
and now i'd like to introduce the
gentleman who's been with the club since
his very inception and continues his
remarkable leadership executive director
tony rich
thank you maurice
well i can't believe it's been almost
two years since i've seen you guys all
in st louis it's great to have you back
welcome welcome back to st louis
the grand chess tour is a series of five
events as maurice mentioned we started
in romania moved on to france croatia
now we're here in st louis for back to
back events with the saint louis rapid
and blitz and then the singfield cup
the grand chess tour players
are comprised of 10 of the very best
players in the world they compete across
the two classical events in romania and
the singfield cup as well as two of the
three blitz events for more than a
million rapid blitz events excuse me for
more than a million dollars in prize
money in addition to the grand chess
tour overall prize fund that will be
awarded at the end of the sink field cup
these really are the best players in the
world and we're so excited to have them
here in st louis as i say at every
players meeting i hope that this is the
best event that they've ever played in i
understand that kovit kind of makes that
difficult with all the masks and lack of
spectators and fans to cheer you on but
i hope you have a great time here and i
hope you really enjoy st louis thank you
thank you tony
and now i'd like to introduce a
gentleman who we have known over
many years
his
and his family's incredible generosity
uh goes without saying it's something i
personally will say i've missed the
banter
the trash talking the jokes
uh that we have between us
over the years
to not have that feels like it's not
even an event without him being here and
us being able to have that kind of fun
and it his personality speaks for itself
i'd like to introduce
i guess what did genie call him the
godfather
since she's not here i will call you
that as well rex the godfather of
american chess rexingfield
[Applause]
thank you maurice what he really meant
to say is
he misses the torture
that he inflicts upon me
but i take it happily
so well welcome players to st louis this
is definitely one of my
favorite times of the year when the
world's best chess players arrive in
this great city let's give them again a
great round of welcome and applause
[Applause]
and i i like others want to thank the
staff of the chess club and the world
chess hall of fame
they work so well together and do a
phenomenal job day in and day out
tony ritz the executive director shannon
bailey the chief curator of the world
chess hall of fame
and joy bray
and all of their staff for everything
they do to make the organization such a
great success thank you all
[Applause]
i also want to thank all the people on
the production side the contractors and
vendors randy and his team at spectrum
studios kevin and his crew at silverback
studios and all those that make the
broadcast and live show an incredible
success
[Applause]
and of course it would never be complete
if we don't recognize and thank
the three greatest commentators in
sports in the world
grand master yasser sarawan maurice
ashley and alejandro ramirez
now i want to tell you about the
hardware to my right i don't mean you
sam
please note our new custom
tiffany cup
we've been working on this for a year
and it's for the st louis rapid and
blitz it's made of sterling silver and
mahogany and has enough space for 100
names
once we fill them up we will need to add
another tier
i'm not sure we will all be around for
the next
uh tier of names well i will be
and
we look forward to the future
generations playing in st louis and i'll
just let you know
what happened
thank you all very much
thank you so much rex
[Applause]
well
this event uh we've had for a number of
years now and this particular one of
course is special because it's the first
time we've been back in st louis in a
couple of years
you do see that there are some players
who we anticipated being here who happen
not to be here
the challenging times that we have have
made it so but we have replaced them
with some fantastic players in their own
right so i'd like to introduce this
illustrious field give them a chance to
stand up and take a bow as i call
their names
some of the stars some of the top
players in the world of chess
here playing in this event beginning
with the youngster from the united
states jeffrey jean
[Applause]
from
vietnam superstar just had a fantastic
online event he should be coming with
all guns blazing lee kroll lamb
[Applause]
uh he's been dominating online play or
at least uh online twitch
play
and
i gotta tell you he's been making chess
that much more popular around the planet
i have to say that
because of the great work he's done
from the united states hikaru nakamura
[Applause]
from
hungary
richard rapport
[Applause]
winning the first classical event of the
year and one of the top players now to
vie for the title from azerbaijan
chakriar mamajira
another wild card playing extremely well
at the moment
looking like world beater
sam shanklin of the united states
[Applause]
one of the leaders right now on the
grand chess tour also playing amazing
chess winning in paris and just coming
off a hot online victory
grand master wesley so
also of the united states i might add
from the united states
linear dominguez
[Applause]
when he's not commentating he's playing
the guy does it all
eight-time russian champion
peters fiddler
[Applause]
and the number three player on the
planet america's finest fabiano koana
[Applause]
okay
wesley's arguing that he's actually
number two in the world uh live rankings
official rankings he's number one in our
hearts wesley we got that
and i will start with him
we'll have a little bit of a q a if you
have a question in the press well i will
give you an opportunity to ask as well
fabi
you mentioned to me earlier you haven't
been here in six months you've been
extremely busy and
of course
you can contextualize as well as anybody
else the situation that kovit has has
put us in what does it feel like to
finally be back in saint louis and have
the chance to play in this event
well it still doesn't really feel like
normal but it's been two years since
i've been here so it's very good to be
back um the last tournament was the sink
the last hornet i played here was the
sinkfield cup uh in 2019 so it feels
like it feels like even longer than two
years it feels like an eternity
but i was watching the
u.s juniors seniors and u.s girls and
it looked like a great success so
hopefully this marks a return to chess
in st louis
um i've been told that you can pull your
mask down when you answer the questions
so shakriar
you come to this event one of the
leaders on the grand chess tour what
does it feel like to to be here and have
the chance to play these next two events
to possibly win it all
first of all i'm very happy to play a
normal chess board
not online
the okay i mean
we will see it's not easy time
normally my life i play here i go
gospital i play chess i will go through
back i mean is life not easy now uh and
i preparing for tournaments also in from
hospitals and i mean not coffee i mean
normal a million problems and for this
reason for me to play in normal chess
and board is very nice
and i hope to play good
show good cheers and interesting cheers
thank you
i'll come down here to the youngster
jeffrey you've played here many many
times but now you have a chance to play
on the grand chess tour what does that
feel like
yeah i mean obviously it's an amazing
feeling uh having a chance to
battle with
these great guys here
and uh okay i have played in uh
the
last year's
st louis rapid and blitz that was online
but over the board it'll be a much
different experience so we'll see how it
goes
lee you are getting this chance to play
right after you had a fabulous online
tournament
get your feeling about playing here in
your home st
louis yeah
so this is also my first tournament
after
in 18 months
over the ball so i play a lot of online
but
over the ball is much different and i
much prefer over the podcast so really
look forward to this tournament and
compete against the top players in the
world here
sam
again
this is like a second home for you in
terms of a lot of events that you've
been able to play here and now you're
back you want a u.s title here you're
coming off a great
series of events you're feeling about
being here playing in this specific
event
well i'm absolutely delighted to be back
in st louis i've been playing here since
my first us championship in 2009 when
the club opened up obviously it's the
most premier events i've been to i'm
very happy making a grand chester w
against the absolute best in the world
and i hope i can put on a good showing
i've never really been historically the
best rapid player out there but i did a
lot of work on that over the course the
pandemic and i guess time will tell if
it pays off
i want to go over to richard uh you have
you had some trouble in the beginning
you weren't able to play in the very
first event
you still gamely decided to make this
big trip to play here
why
uh yeah i had some health issues
uh before the event in romania so i had
to i was forced to cancel it
and basically speaking i haven't played
such a top level event throughout the
pandemic at all so i'm very glad that
you know finally i have a chance to be
back on the board and play with the best
i will go to hikaru next ikaru
we know you haven't played
any over the board events in quite some
time you've been playing a lot of online
and a lot of streaming as well
in addition to the question of what it
feels like to be back playing at the
board itself
i'm curious what you feel your form will
be like
now that you're able to sit across from
players and play against them once again
yeah i mean it's been uh two years since
i played last played the world wrapping
blitz in moscow at the end of 2019 um
and much like fabiano my last time here
in st louis was uh for the sink filled
cups so i think you know
uh i would argue that i think playing
online and playing over the board are
quite similar i mean i i've seen wesley
do it so if anyone's my inspiration to
try and play well online and then return
and play well over the board it would be
wesley um and then just in general i
would say being back here it's amazing i
think you know
uh 2009 was the first time i was here
for the us championship which i won and
just to see the see what it was back
then just you know small little club um
and to see what rex and jeannie have
done since then it's just just amazing
and hopefully when chess comes back
there will be a lot more events here in
st louis
lanier
you
haven't played that much that i've seen
you've had some opportunities to play in
some events what does it mean to be here
playing in this one
well it's great uh
first of all i enjoy much more playing
just
face to face and then online
and i i played mostly online last year
so it's great to to be able to to play
finally uh in person
also uh
my my last event uh here in saint louis
was the rabbit and blitz from 2019 so
it's been two years uh and now it's it's
different because
uh having been living here for for two
years uh now
i feel like i'm playing from home now
for for the first time which is also
quite nice so let's see how it goes but
i'm i'm very happy to to to be back
peter
you are
you are a commentator
i've been doing a lot of that but you're
also a star player and it seems like
you've been playing a little bit more as
well
put it in context you're being back here
normally as a commentator but sometimes
as a player and now the chance that you
to come to one of your favorite places
well as you well know i was slated to to
see it sort of alongside you and uh uh
make fun of all these guys and now
you will you will have an opportunity to
make fun of me which is
less fun for me but more fun for you i
suppose but i'm extremely happy to be
back in st louis i've been coming back
since that first first visit in 2016
which is somewhat similar as i was also
a very last minute replacement for my
compatriot in uh in that event and it
really does feel like coming home i've
i've enjoyed every single visit it's a
fantastic feeling to be here in whatever
whatever all and
now that i'm playing i'm going to enjoy
playing
we will be making fun of you yes that's
as you should
finally you wesley at least question for
myself
uh you are sort of the man with a target
on your back you've done extremely well
in the two events you won one you tied
for second in another uh clearly there
are people who are chasing you down as
well so there is some pressure on you
but you've been playing so well of late
you're feeling about being sort of
the leader right now although maxime is
technically in the ahead but he's played
three events the only two
dealing with that
but also back here at a place where
you've had tremendous success yeah i was
hoping maxine wouldn't be here but
it's already here
so no i think uh
well first of all it's very good to be
back in saint louis and see familiar
faces
i haven't seen you in a couple years
also
joy
and rex and
also the arbiters also gene is not here
i was really looking forward to see her
again
uh i think
the one with the target on the back is
fabiano because he's the highest rated
also
currently number two in the world
um
so i unless i
overtake him on classical ratings i
think he's he'll always have a target on
his back
uh
also since hikaru mentioned a kind word
to me i also want to say i'm a big fan
of him in in bits
and
i spent countless hours watching his
twitch
so now it's very good to watch his his
blitz games over the board also
i i must admit this year is very weird
kobe does really change the world for
example
7 out of 10 players here are all living
in the united states
so
it's a very unnatural time but i'm very
glad to play over the board once again i
think it's
the serious chess also
uh i'm excited to play classical chess
once again which
which you can't really do online so i'm
just very glad to be here and i'd like
to thank saint louis chess club also
grand jester for for insisting in having
this event i mean at some point couple
weeks ago i thought there's a chance
this event could be postponed but
thank you to all the people for fighting
and not letting that happen
that sounds almost like a winner speech
didn't it
well
uh
i have to say i'm happy that
the players are here as well
part of the reason why is because it's
rare that we have the whole gang
together not just the players but the
commentators and the broadcast crew
in one place of course along with joy
and tony
and rex and the whole
leonard by the way as well otez doing
all of the digital work everybody's here
as well as well as well as eric so
it's great to be home let's just let me
just say that it's great to be home well
i will now
oh i will first introduce my
co-commentators
i earlier i called them legends and
somebody said i overstated one of these
guys
credentials but i'll call them legends
the legends
alejandro ramirez and yasser sirowan
[Applause]
please
yeah sir are we going that far back
seriously
would you agree all right more more or
less
thanks for that yes that's the kind of
scintillating commentary you can expect
from yeah
i am now going to introduce once again
executive director tony rich thank you
[Applause]
the most important part of the evening
as far as the players are concerned is
the drawing of lots for the st louis
rapid and blitz there will be two draws
for numbers
the first number the players will draw
is underneath these beautiful replica
arches that commemorate the st louis
arch the saint louis arch was built in
1963
666
okay 19 he was there
uh it is 630 feet tall and 630 feet wide
that's going to be a really good trivia
question for you later is is the arch
taller or wider it's the same thing in
fact this is called a hyperbolic cosine
i'll talk to you all about the math
later on if you'd like
so
as we call the players up we'll ask them
to first pick an arch underneath each
arch is the pairing number for the rapid
portion of the event in addition to that
there will be pairing numbers in the
front here for the blitz portion so the
players are asked to first draw their
rapid number and then to draw their
blitz number
to assist me in drawing of lots is our
chief arbiter of the event chris bird
chris bird actually was here in 2009 for
our first us chess championship uh he
and i were the deputy arbiters
underneath
under carol joracki who unfortunately
passed away earlier this year carol was
probably one of the best arbiters i knew
i certainly learned a lot from her
and enjoyed having her in st louis every
time she came
but without further ado chris if you can
join me up here and we will draw some
lots
we'll go in feed a
classical rating order which means we
begin with grand master fabiano caruana
fabiano chooses the center arch in the
front and his pairing number is number
four
and then fabiano
that's for you yeah
and number ten
next up to the stage grand master
chakriar mehmed yarov
chakra yard chooses pairing number five
for the rapid
three and number three
next up to the stage is grandmaster
wesley so
pick an arch any arch
number three
and for his blitz he's got to tell us
number nine
next up from hungary grand master
richard rapport
richard has pairing number 10
for the rapid
five
and number five for the blitz
next up
grandmaster lenier dominguez
linear picks an arch
number two
and also number two
chris i don't know man
next up grand master hikaru nakamura
the car has pairing number six for the
rapid and
number six and number six for the blitz
next up is grand master peter svidler
for the rapid peter has number seven
and number one for the blitz
grand master jeffrey jean
jeffrey has pairing number nine for the
rapid
seven
and number seven for the blitz
next up is grandmaster sam shanklin
number one for the rapid
and number eight for the blitz
and last but not least liam lee
let's hope that it's pairing number
eight and four eight
and number four
okay so to announce our round one rapid
pairings
wesley you want to pay attention for
this part
wrong one we have sam shanklin versus
richard rapport linear dominguez versus
jeffrey zhang wesley so versus liam lee
fabiano carlawana versus peter svidler
and shakuryan mehmet versus hikaru
nakamura don't forget guys you can
follow all of the action on
grandchesstour.org
and the games will begin at 3 p.m
starting tomorrow the 11th of august and
they'll go for the next five days thank
you very much
thank you so much tony and chris
well that's it now it's up to the
players to regale us with all their
amazing moves i'm sure there'll be one
or two mistakes that'll creep in
not that many guys
but we'll be having a lot of fun as tony
said join us online and we will be
starting our show
at 2 50 central time
and that is 3 50 on the east coast
it'll be an amazing event a start of a
wonderful summer of chess or
continuation i should say of a wonderful
summer of chess here in st louis thank
you all for joining us and have a
wonderful night
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
you